I'm curious uh because I only know you
from streaming well like when did you
start streaming and what were you doing
before streaming because I don't know um
so I started streaming just about three
years ago so it's been a pretty quick
it's only been three years I feel like
you've been on the platform forever
um I'm like one of the newer streamers I
guess right I just got lucky I guess and
it's going pretty well in a short time
like because all my friends right like I
think Leslie just hit her eight year
streaming thing I think Lily hit like 10
or 11 years or something
like everyone's been doing stuff for a
long time I've been streaming for like
three years basically right before
covert base oh what were you doing
before streaming before that I was a
software developer
um so oh hell yeah pretty much had a
regular job and everything oh right I
went back to school to try and get a
better job because it was hard to get
promoted right the tech industry is
usually you never get promoted you have
to apply to a different company right
and if you apply with a better degree
you'll get a better job doesn't matter
what you're doing right
so did you grow up in LA or grew up in
L.A went to the Bay Area or School
worked in the Bay Area and then went to
school right um and then
this is kind of weird but I I'm not good
at like making friends kind of thing
um so what I used to do was I would
leave streams on because it felt like
people were talking to me it's really
cringed it's really cringe but um
basically I I would just go to work or I
would just go to school come home and
just play League of Legends yeah that's
what I did back then and then I started
streaming because I watched a lot of
streams right
um because it just felt like you had
someone that was talking to you when you
came here because it was like school I
would talk to classmates but it's not
like we were friends that would hang out
yeah yeah and then you'd come home and
there's just no one to talk to
completely quiet kind of weird right um
so I'll leave streams on in the
background to just have some noise of
someone talking yeah
um and then I started streaming to like
kind of do the reverse and I was like oh
maybe I'll make some friends yeah yeah
yeah and I made tons of friends so yeah
that worked pretty well like like you
you sound so confident yeah yeah well I
mean so I've played with Connor yeah we
played three games as well yeah yeah
yeah and then I don't think we've ever
played but I've met you a couple times
yeah yeah yeah and I said hi to you once
yeah we had like a two second
interaction yeah
um so what do you think is like the best
game to make friends with
definitely not among us
I thought you'd lose friendships yeah
um but uh I don't I'm not actually sure
like probably a teamwork maybe right um
but I think the biggest thing is when
you play multiple different games yeah
right um like when it's just someone you
just asked to play a random game yeah
yeah I agree what what was the game for
you in in your case like what was the
one that like Minecraft was the first
one oh really yeah that makes sense yeah
so I'm assuming you guys know OTV right
yeah yes um I was friends with Lily she
invited me to the Minecraft server were
you friends before streaming or uh yeah
yeah oh wow she was actually the one who
told me I should try streaming oh wow
and then she just invited me the
Minecraft server met a lot of people
there and that's pretty much how it
mostly started because I was gonna say I
was like it seems uh I'm sure anyone
who's watched this has tried streaming
or or being a YouTuber it's like you
know it's really hard to get that
initial kind of growth yeah from like
one viewer to 100 is like very hard
especially
um
how did you go from like one viewer to
10 or 100 is it purely from the collabs
or I really don't no I just played games
with the people that liked playing games
with me and that's
since I had like a regular job I never
really thought about yeah I didn't
really care right outside this is really
just for fun well did you quit because
yeah I've always been curious did you
quit your job because you were like okay
I actually really enjoy streaming uh
this is the job I want to do or did you
just kind of like hate your job and
we're looking for something new
kind of I I mostly just because
streaming was more fun yeah and just
made more sense and I think I've made
more money streaming anyway so yeah yeah
kind of worked out yeah because I think
we all have a similar experience where
we went to school studied for a certain
subject found out we hated the subject
and uh kind of like uh yeah let's let's
try content creation you know yeah not
used to my mechanical engineering degree
oh man I'm sorry well you're one day one
day yeah one day one day I'll build like
a table
on streams yeah
then I feel like I'm getting value out
of it yeah yeah hearing a story even
reminds me have you have you seen Bocce
The Rock
um oh that's one of my favorites
recently so I I have to of course you'd
like it I have to confess I haven't
watched the whole thing but okay clips
and I like the clips I've seen that's
like watching like you are kind of like
bocci's final form I think like the the
end of like the journey you know start
off with like a lot of like anxiety and
just want to make friends and look at
him now guys look at him now he's on
trash days now yeah yeah in Japan yeah
the biggest success I've made being on
trash taste pods let's go
the name trash taste is that
um so we were kind of uh brainstorming a
lot of different names because we knew
we wanted to make a podcast and we
weren't gonna let Joey name it because
he would name it uh the anime podcast or
something or the podcast did you have a
podcast called the anime podcast I did
yeah
that's a real it was the anime show but
to be fair I wasn't the one that came up
with that name okay yeah it was the
radio it's the anime guy yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I was like it was I was doing a
radio show in Australia and they wanted
me and my girlfriend to do like an anime
themed podcast and they were like let's
just call it the anime show and I was
like well [__] I don't have any other
ideas so sure let's do that Joe was like
well that was my first suggestion yeah
yeah yeah you read my mind yeah I think
that's good though I think a lot of
people when you're trying to come up
with an idea yeah a lot of content
creators struggle with they plan too
much and don't actually do it because
they're worried about making it perfect
from the start yeah I think it's better
just do it yeah not great just do it
yeah it'll get better exactly exactly
um so we knew that we wanted to kind of
Market ourselves as an anime podcast
initially but also we knew we wanted to
Branch out of anime so we wanted
something that was like ah you thought
about this oh yeah yeah yeah I landed
out yeah uh I mean loud I mean I I
learned my lesson especially because
it's like calling myself the anime man I
was like I've basically just pigeonholed
myself so instead you called yourself
trash yes
it was one of three names that we
narrowed it down to uh one was trash
taste one was Men of culture
I'm glad you didn't go with that one
yeah for some reason and the last one
was The Salt Room all terrible man oh
yeah yeah trash taste sounds really nice
it sounds better than before all of a
sudden yeah yeah
yeah so we ended up with trash Chase
luck yeah because uh We've we've all
been creating content for quite a long
time so we had learned you know some
people they just go with their first
username that comes up with uh you know
that they come up with cheers
I've had it since I was like 10 years
old it's good yeah I'm just gonna ask
you like where'd that name come from I
just made it up when I was like 10 years
old thought it sounded cool and it still
does I think
do you mind I think I was smarter when I
was 10 than right now I feel like I was
more creative how do you have a better
sense of naming [__] at 10 years old
than I do at age 20. you know I have no
clue but I don't think I could do it
again my first my first username was
Donkey man five but I spelled donkey
incorrectly and it didn't have a y at
the end because I didn't know how to
spell it was Donkey there's a guy who
spelled donkey incorrectly and he's
pretty cool I've heard really donkey oh
yeah all that too yeah yeah nice
hilarious guy why did I take five though
why men five like I surely the donkey
man was I don't [__] there but
luckily they didn't stick with that now
people are rambling they call you donkey
man nobody called me now it would have
been a really different podcast if it
was the anime man geek and Donkey man
so I chose Sea Dog which isn't that much
better
at least there's no [__] weird name
uh number in it yeah yeah I kind of love
numbers are always bad it was bad yeah I
kind of lucked out with my username um
people think oh it's such a cool name
and it's such a unique name and luckily
it was just like a family nickname that
I had growing up and it was my very
first my very first account which was a
Hotmail account uh yes that's showing my
age right now dude your mom came in
clutch with that yeah my mom came in
clutch thank you very much that'd be
nice to inherit usernames actually let's
we should start that like your kid has
to your kid your kid has to inherit your
username online sounds crazy no that
sounds great because then we'll get like
in like what if your kid's not as cool
as you are my name is not cool
[Music]
we could take it so that like after like
five generations it'll start sounding
already [__] weird and [__] up yeah
it's like so son no matter what you do
your nickname will be Boris mcswady uh
that's just the username curse names
would be fun like this should be like a
thing like a government rule yeah yeah
that all usernames username should have
second names as well like surnames like
oh yeah I'm from the gigock bloodline
actually yeah that's what I mean like we
should have it what about those guys
whose usernames are like XX Naruto oh
that's great that's the greatest imagine
that you're shining uh you go to the
doctor like uh yeah sorry it's XX Naruto
yeah oh yes
two people with their hands up like what
it's like wait YouTube yeah
it's like a narusasu 69 uh do we have
anyone here is that with or without an
underscore I think I've had a bunch of
different shitty names because I could
never decide on one I like I think one
of them was Xbox best CMC as well you're
one of those dudes who would fight the
PS5 and Xbox and be like this one's
better for sure yeah oh God yeah Connor
was definitely it sounds like I was like
a super toxic gamer I was that annoying
like 14 year olds you hear on like Xbox
way back oh God squeaker yeah not a
squeaker competitive
sometimes we've played I feel like you
are a competitive yeah very much so what
was it that I think I saw a Ludwig beat
jump King yeah and you're like I'm
beating jump King now yeah yeah I beat
all the jump kings that he beat uh yeah
invested in the game unless it's
competitive unless he's beating
something yeah unless yeah yeah and
you'll just admit to that you'll be like
100 to beat level yeah yeah for sure he
doesn't take the L line down did you
beat his like timer I don't know uh I
think his first attempt but he's he's
definitely done better runs which I I
should his tone of voice changed a
little when he talked about the
competitive like yeah yeah yeah he's
like well I think he did a little better
he definitely is still better than me at
it I gotta get better though but I did
something Maps quicker than him okay
yeah meanwhile me and Joey are just
single player games which is probably
why we haven't played anything together
yet yeah we're just like I'm out there
have you played that no there's a new
expansion I've heard
I don't that was the PVP one I didn't
play that person yeah ultimate socks and
PVP it's boring well you do that cheese
Strat where you roll around in the spot
yeah I heard it got patched though oh
it's just it's just over so quick and
it's kind of like I imagine how it feels
like a duel in real life yeah where it's
like you just get shots
and then it ends in a split second yeah
yeah you're kind of like well that's not
fun yeah yeah yeah but then I just watch
occasional YouTube videos where someone
owns someone with a 10 000 gigabrange
Strat and then you're like okay that's
fun but it's for a funny video but how
many times did it take you to to get
this to work like this probably took
like thousands it recorded for like 10
hours yeah yeah three seconds yeah
probably yeah yeah no I'm def I'm
definitely gonna play Elden ring
sometime I'm that kind of guy
okay one game of the year
but I'm that guy who I just only watch
or play things when I feel like it one
day I know this like this happened
plenty of times with like different
anime or different movies where it's
always been on my two watch lists a
woman who happens but uh wait sit you
haven't watched it either you haven't
watched it yet I haven't watched like I
kind of know what happens because it's
such a big show oh yeah I feel like I
could recite like so we'll watch it
together yeah which means we still don't
have to watch it yeah or maybe I don't
know he's never gonna watch he's never
gonna oh yeah probably neither will I
now we can just blame each other exactly
I promise I promise to watch it with gig
out here and we just haven't gone around
to it just use each other if anyone's
like why haven't you watched it's one of
the greatest I mean I promise to watch
it with a friend and yeah
time zones now we both have a good
excuse yeah okay I'm saying this now you
know I'll watch Full Metal Alchemist uh
when it's like gonna watch this same
same right all right
but like I'll just wake up one day
sometimes and I will just be like feel
like playing or watching this random
movie or game that I haven't like heard
of or remembered from like years ago and
I'll just like Marathon it all in one
day that is exactly what I do sometimes
too yeah um and it's like I just
sometimes I get so hyped for a game that
by the time it comes out I'm just not
hyped for it anymore like oh yeah yeah
that happens so many times yeah like
like it happened with cyberpunk uh I was
so so [__] hyped for cyberpunk uh
then obviously it came out even before
like the whole controversy with the bugs
or stuff
um I just you know I was just like well
I'm done I was like I got my hype it's
been too long and then I didn't even
play it and I'm like okay I don't feel
like playing it and then everything came
out
um and then one day I just woke up like
a month ago and I was like I feel like
playing
marathoned it all in a week and I was
like yeah had a good time I'm glad I
waited for all the bugs to get fixed
yeah no that was part of the fun
what is it yes it's all broken [__] and
it was all funny you must have like
Skyrim or something yeah I have never
played Skyrim I'm more of a competitive
gamer I know I'm like no it was terrible
but it was funny when it broke yeah so
he didn't like the game he liked that it
was I'm kind of glad that it did have a
lot of bugs because it made it more
bearable because at least well you
enjoyed it because you were streaming
bugs made it more bearable well because
it was like you'd be doing this [__]
Mission while you're just shooting a guy
for 10 minutes and then he'd stop
floating there were bullet sponges that
was a thing yeah there's so many bullet
sponges so many oh I was in there for
the world and the characters and the
story and yeah
it looked cool like aesthetically yeah I
think cyberpunk is uh as a non-game here
I think 2077 is highly underrated I
think uh I think CD projekt Red did a
[__] fantastic job building this
world yeah yeah
like I think the unfortunately the best
content in cyberpunk 2077 is the side
missions I think the main story was a
bit cliche a lot of the times but there
were some really [__] interesting
side missions uh which kind of all
skipped so he didn't get the best yeah I
knew any side missions
I wanted to be done there are two there
are two types of games
you mainly play competitive games those
as well yeah like balance or something
like that yeah you're very competitive
you pretend not to be but you definitely
are I can tell I could sense it it's
like an aura kind of but
I know I know I I know when someone's
competitive it's sort of different like
I don't try to be good because I want to
win okay I want to do weird stuff so
like uh a lot of people see like and
Valerian is a good example
um I try to get good enough where I can
do silly plays that look funny right
knifing people is right like it's just
not a thing you normally do yeah I try
to do it because it's funny right so I
waste a lot of time trying to figure out
how to do that better yeah it's not good
at ranking up it's not good for winning
but it's good at uh making good Clips
there's a time where I played against
like a pro player I knifed them like
multiple times and he was losing it it
was really really funny so I'm
competitive in the sense where I want to
be good enough to do funny things but
I'm not competitive because I want to
win the thing right right I feel like I
feel like it was after the Among Us era
where even people who didn't say they
were competitive they started to get
like a competitive side to them because
I I kind of miss the whole I didn't miss
the Among Us craze I was very very late
to it and I played my first game like a
month after the craze started or
something and I Remember by the time I
started my first game everyone had like
Min maxed everything yeah they were like
okay where were you what uh what room
were you in what challenges were you
doing and I was like I was uh I haven't
even learned the map yeah I think he
played one game with uh toast and toast
have just memorized literally everything
in existence and I was like well this
[__] sucks in our group a lot yeah a
lot of mods a lot of weird stuff to
Spruce it up which made it fun but
definitely to some extent we were just
like we've done everything there was to
have been yeah yeah I had another friend
who lost it uh because I voted him out
because he was being sweaty and you know
he wasn't there his foster yeah and he
lost it we went like full like light
like at the end of Death Note
Johnny you idiot what are you doing I'm
not the Imposter I'm not sus and then
just like go and I was like well I just
kind of just kind of made the game less
fun so bye-bye oh my God that is
probably the biggest install he gives
everyone mine